so after facebook went back up uh
mark zuckerberg actually dropped eight
billion on his network saw that and it
says that he is set to keep on a steady
decline because of what's app instagram
and facebook being down for six hours
damn it sounds like facebook it's it's
very strange like i'm not conspiracy guy
but it's weird there's that
whistleblower and then the site the next
day goes down like oh it was on us
nobody did it and like what are you
erasing in there what data are you
getting rid of i i think the really
interesting thing is that they've known
for a long time that their product
is not good for children like and it
just isn't for example when she was
testifying she was like our algorithm
can show you that when you start
googling
healthy recipes as a as a young girl
yeah it leads you very quickly into
anorexia promoting behavior it's so
different oh so literally and they knew
this and it goes on and on so the
rohingya in burma they are a minority in
burma they were the the military junta
or the you know the power structure was
hijacking facebook pages to spread
false stories
that caused mobs of people to go kill
rohingya so the genocide is being blamed
on how they are manipulating the
facebook algorithm to spread false
information the military is now facebook
goes what are we supposed to do it was a
major problem so it's really interesting
that facebook is think about this yeah
just like with um tobacco companies
you're a human being
you get a great job you're working for
i don't know philip morris yep you got a
great house you got you know your kids
are going to school you have a swimming
pool you got a great community and you
look around and as the evidence starts
mounting you realize [ __ ] my product
kills people but then you do this you go
i'm just supplying a demand
you can do that for just so long until
your kids start coming home going hey
dad
this [ __ ] is killing people
and you know it and i i it's very
interesting what's going on facebook
because i wonder what's going to happen
within the ranks you go i'm making
millions of dollars but the [ __ ]
instagram tick tock all this stuff is
not good for my own children it's not
good for me it's not good for anybody
we know with mental health like it's so
unhealthy for everybody adults to
children like it's so toxic at what
point do they take some responsibility
go this isn't good it's dividing people
we're spreading misinformation a lot of
myself here's my question how do you
take responsibility because we know that
foreign nationals
china russia israel whoever it might be
are hijacking these platforms and and
creating dissension in america that's
what they want that's what they were
like uh rogan had that mike baker on the
cia and he and they played an interview
from a russian he was kgb and this was
their plan like they they they want to
pit us against each other
the woke movement the cancel like they
want all this device so they just push
all this like
information is their plan yeah a lot of
yeah a lot of it is russian intelligence
yeah pushing the narrative yeah he's
like you know people think it's like
james bond like we're spies he's like
that's like ten percent of what we do
he's like because he was a whistleblower
he's like what what they do now their
focus is all social media of course
because they can go and divide so much
further you can create
wars
chaos you can just spread a story about
how the rohingya are enslaving
yeah my thing is if you're mark
zuckerberg and you're worth who i mean
50 100 million billion dollars
at what point you go man this is not
good you don't need any more money
you're all set bubba you're good
at what point do you take some and go
shut it down yeah you go man we could
something else can pop up but i think
him as a
american he's go man we create this
thing this is not what i intend for it
to do it's gotten way out of hand now
that i've seen the analytics i see how
you know it's crushing young people and
spreading misinformation i'm gonna shut
it down here's the problems you got see
how many people work for facebook i was
gonna say that same thing too so you're
responsible for so many people's
employment yeah and you're making a good
point i think no i'm gonna [ __ ] on that
point there so
so let's say they have say they have a
thousand they don't save a thousand
employees okay
we have a thousand employees
sixty thousand sixty thousand not only
do you have sixty thousand but you also
there's a lot of good that it does too
right so people it brings people
together creates communities it helps
organize for good causes that's the
other that's if that's the flip side of
it what i think you might see
is
more regulation if you're under 18 you
don't get to be on facebook i mean you
don't get to be on tick tock you don't
get to be on instagram good luck that's
unrealistic it's unrealistic yeah
you have to shut it down i have a 13
year old i i am not opposed to saying to
my 13 year old you're never allowed on
social media i don't think it's good for
you it's just not realistic you know
it's shooting these things because our
friends are on it yeah how do you stop
porn how do you stop these kids who are
10 years old
watching porn and it gets into their
brain they'll find a way of course
it is it is the problem i don't know
what it is it's our problem it is our it
is our generation's problem quick
question i'm just trying to understand
it a little bit more so what is that
like when he said he lost
all that money like how did it how did
somebody's work 128 billion dollars so
by getting shut down with advertising
all this stuff guys losing eight billion
dollars okay wow stock people probably
were like oh man they're not that stable
so they're just like pulling out yep
selling stocks yeah advertising
okay
it's pretty interesting
i don't know man i mean just watch my
[ __ ] instagram that's all you got to
do guys and that's where you're going
it's interesting that they uh
it's just interesting that the hold they
have on society like these me it's a
monopoly for sure it's a monopoly i tell
you that's worldwide
companies that control all the
information the [ __ ] are we doing
i i don't know
i don't know it's dangerous